mutant zombie creatures falling bodies
and the Hudson River only slightly less
polluted than it is now The Walking Dead
dead city is a continuation of The
Walking Dead Saga focusing on the
tumultuous relationship between the
baseball bat wielding Negan and totally
not emotionally traumatized after
watching her husband get murdered Maggie
so join me as we take a leisurely stroll
down the beautiful streets of Manhattan
explain its ending and what it could
mean for a potential season two the true
protagonist of dead city is Maggie Reed
who we first find overlooking the
post-apocalyptic Manhattan skyline New
York was one of the epicenters of the
zombie virus and to contain it the
government had all the tunnels and
bridges linking Manhattan to the
mainland destroyed trapping hundreds of
thousands years later it seems seemingly
abandoned with the spattering of Rogue
survivors fighting for control now
Maggie isn't venturing to this hell hole
for the fun of it her son Herschel was
kidnapped by this season's main
antagonist a man known by the croat and
and you know when this guy plays a
villain we're in for one hell of a ride
in order to get her son back Maggie will
have to team up with the very man who
killed her husband the ruthless Negan
Smith who is currently on the run from
the marshals of new Babylon for killing
a magistrate and four of his men she
tracks him down believing that negan's
story and insight into the croat may
help her get her son back but why would
Negan help Maggie considering their past
one Negan has nowhere to go he's on the
run and two Ginny Jenny's a young girl
he's taken under his wing after her
father was killed and Maggie promises to
protect her at the bricks a walled
farming community in exchange for
negan's help according to Maggie the
crowette came to the bricks demanding
regular tributes of grain taking
Herschel as collateral thus she wants
the crow at dead not only to get her son
back but to end the exploitation of her
people what Negan doesn't know however
is that this is all a lie yes the croat
has her son but he doesn't want grain he
wants Negan so by teaming up with Negan
and handing him over to the crow at she
hopes to get her son back and bring down
the man who killed her husband as we
begin the final episode titled Doma Smo
a Croatian phrase meaning we are home
Ginny and Negan are reunited she left
the bricks in search of Negan disobeying
his orders to be with the man who kept
her safe knowing that staying with him
would jeopardize her safety he tells her
the truth about what happened to her
father Negan killed him and taking her
under his wing was just a guilt trip ew
you're just a dead that I had to pay
Negan probably doesn't really believe
this but it's a necessary evil to keep
her safe he'd rather lose her forever
and keep her safe than have her tag
along and die so Ginny ends up leaving
under the care of Marshall Armstrong and
heads back to the bricks with Negan and
Maggie on their own they traveled to the
Staten Island Ferry Terminal where Negan
gets suspicious you are inside the
sewers for Jenny what do you think she
was trying to tell me in the sewers
Maggie told Ginny that the crowd had
stolen her son and all their food and
grain from the bricks but Ginny knows
this is a lie when she was there she saw
plenty of food in a full Silo this is
why Ginny runs away and writes the word
liar Ginny who hasn't spoken since the
death of her father says her first line
of the show here saying I
want you to no but is cut off I think
she wanted to warn Negan that Maggie was
a liar and if Negan knew that not to
trust her intentions this causes him to
get real suspicious of Maggie ultimately
culminating in the two having a knife
battle over a horde of bloodthirsty
zombies and before we continue if you
like these types of videos be sure to
like And subscribe every little bit
helps the channel out with the arrival
of the croat and his men Negan is
brought into custody and the croat's
plan is partially revealed he heard
through a former member of the saviors
the group of survivors led by Negan that
there was a story of a pregnant woman
who watched her husband get killed by
Negan so the croat used this knowledge
to seek her out and use her to bring
Negan in the plan works and the croat is
a man of his word releasing Herschel in
exchange for Negan but Herschel is far
from thankful for his rescue he believes
that his mother is more obsessed with
getting revenge on Negan than actually
saving him seemed like he cared more
about
revenge or whatever in fact he felt
safer with the crawd because unlike
being at the bricks he never had to
worry about when the next bad thing was
going to happen Maggie has definitely
been an overprotective mother chastising
her son for not following the rules and
skipping out on classes she knows how
vicious the world can be and is merely
trying to protect her son the last thing
she told Herschel before he was
kidnapped was that he was stupid for
grabbing a shovel to fight against the
croat and his men so there's a lot to
unpack in their relationship meanwhile a
scene with Marshall Armstrong and the
powers that be in new Babylon set up an
interesting thread for season two this
woman simply credited as new Babylon
leader wants to know everything about
the methane building up underground
Manhattan we've seen bubbling methane
Pockets throughout the streets and this
methane could be used for fuel in
episode 3 we learned that the croat had
been using dead Walkers and storing them
in the sewers to create methane the gas
can be pressure
into a liquid fuel that's why we can see
the croat's men rounding up walkers by
the Dozen collecting them as fuel death
is no end
it is our fuel it seems the people of
new Babylon have been alerted to this
discovery and will want to claim it for
themselves which brings us to negan's
Meetup with dhamma which literally means
lady in Croatian dhamma is the real
leader of the barazi the group of
croat's men who control much of
Manhattan she has headquartered her
people in a rundown theater apt
considering she believes politics to be
nothing more than a performance for what
is politics if not performance which is
exactly why she needs Negan she needs a
leader who can show he can be a monster
one who can beat his enemies into
submission so when dhamma heard from the
croat there's this man who fits this
description she sent him out on a
mission to find him the croat sees
dhamma as a mother figure even referring
to Negan and dama's meeting as a mother
and father getting together and it seems
as though it's all water under the
bridge between the croat and Negan
considering their past the croat was
negan's torturer and when he disobeyed
an order in and killed a young girl
Negan shot off his ear the croat now
understands what Negan did was exactly
what the barazi need a leader who isn't
afraid to keep his own in line and do
what it takes to keep the stability of
his people so the dhamma basically gives
Negan a deal helper lead the barazi and
unite the settlements of Manhattan under
one rule so they can create an
indomitable Force to crush the marshals
of new Babylon who want them for their
natural resource she believes a quote
Clash of civilizations is inevitable and
the missing piece is a strong leader who
isn't afraid to do what it takes to win
even if it means becoming a monster and
what better person than Negan The dhamma
gives Negan a morbid box containing the
severed pinky toe of Herschel claiming
that at any point she can go back and
take much more should Negan not comply
so negan's basically trapped he either
helps them out or Maggie Ginny Herschel
and others over at the bricks May face
the barazi's Wrath and to make matters
even more complicated it seems as though
Herschel has developed a connection with
the dhamma not only did he say he'd
rather be back with her but Maggie
uncovers a series of drawings one in
particular that hints he may have been
let out of his confinement to draw
there's even a sketch of the dhamma
herself the dhamma Tells Negan that
Herschel opened up to her and felt safe
around her perhaps she was the good cop
to the croat's bad so I think there's a
little bit more going on here than what
we're being told the final shot of the
season is a split screen of Negan and
Maggie's face it's a metaphor for their
relationship two people who started so
far apart coming together and
understanding one another only to be
ripped apart yet again but if they're
going to find a way out of their
situation it can only be done through
each other but what did you think of
dead city is this a good addition to The
Walking Dead universe or should this
have stayed dead let me know your
thoughts and theories in the comments
below thanks for watching please make
sure to like And subscribe and for more
bad takes you can follow me on Twitter
and Instagram at thinkstoryyt until next
time remember
that's over